-Our next guest
is a talented actress
you know from films like
"Reminiscence" and "Dumbo."
You can see her
in "The Last of Us,"
which premieres January 15th
on HBO.
Let's take a look.
-They're saying it's a virus,
some kind of parasite.
-Is it from terrorists?
-We don't know.
-Are we sick?
-No, of course not.
-Why did things blow up?
-No cellphone, no radio.
Minute ago,
the newsman wouldn't shut up.
-How do you know?
-What?
-How do you know we're not sick?
-Please welcome to the show
Nico Parker, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hi! How are you?
-I'm good. How are you?
-I'm wonderful.
I'm so happy you're here.
-Thank you for having me.
-This is a film
based on a very popular
video game.
-Yes.
-Post-apocalyptic.
You got to see it at a premiere
with an audience full of people.
Was it really fun?
-We did.
We watched the first episode,
which, you know,
I'm prevalent in.
And it was amazing,
but I suck at watching myself.
I hate nothing more.
So I'm --
You know, I'm sitting there,
and I'm, like, gearing up.
You know, some people leave
as soon as it starts
because they just can't face it.
But I was thinking like,
"If I'm in the room,
no one can be like,
'God, she was so bad,'
because I'm right next to them,
so I was like,
"I should just be there
just so that no one
can say anything."
-That's very smart.
Did you stand up
before it started and say,
"Just so you all know,
I'm gonna be staying"?
[ Laughter ]
-I was wearing a very bright
dress purposefully
so I could be like,
"Do you all see
that I'm right here
in front of you?"
-This is based on a pandemic,
obviously a bit more severe than
the one we just went through.
How did you spend your pandemic?
-Um, it was super relaxed.
I was at home in London
with my family.
I was doing the typical
school Zooming,
which was amazing
'cause you join the maths Zoom,
and then you mute it and you go
downstairs for a couple of hours
and then you come back,
and it's finished.
-Wow!
What a celebration of education.
-It was incredible.
[ Laughter ]
But I'd come back,
and they'd be like,
"Why are you still here
three hours later?"
Like, "Sorry. I just really
lost track of the equations."
[ Laughter ]
But it was a good
learning lesson for me
'cause it taught me that me and
my sister cannot live together.
Butting heads was intense.
But it was great.
-Is your sister older
or younger?
-Older.
-Okay. I heard a story
that maybe one of the reasons
she's tricky to live with is
because she's brutally honest,
because I heard that she met,
at the time,
Prime Minister Boris Johnson
in the U.K.
-Yes.
-And what did she say to him?
-She was at "Harry Potter
and The Cursed Child,"
which is her safe space.
And she saw him,
and she went up,
and she tapped him
on the shoulder, and she went,
"Um, excuse me, Mr. Johnson,"
and he turned around,
was like, "Yes?"
I think he was expecting
a compliment of some sort.
And she goes, "You're a [bleep]
Enjoy the show."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-It's very nice.
It's very sweet that she also
wanted him to enjoy the show.
-That is her way, yeah.
Yeah.
She's an absolute legend, yeah.
-You -- Your parents
are both in the business.
Thandiwe Newton, a fantastic
actor in her own right.
And then your father
is a film director, Ol Parker.
And tell me, are they --
When you audition for things,
do you get feedback from them?
What has life been like
with them in the same career?
-It's -- It's amazing, I think,
because me and my dad
do a lot of self-tapes together
which is great,
'cause it's just like cheating.
[ Laughter ]
And so we do
a lot of self-tapes together.
So I've gotten way more
comfortable.
-So this is when you have
to audition for a role
and you can't be there
in person,
you get an actual film director
to film yours, right.
[ Laughter ]
-But so, you know, me and him,
he's very good at kind of
keeping it parent
and then professional,
very good at that dynamic.
But even after, you know,
been doing it
a couple years now,
and after every single
first take, I kind of sit there,
and we both kind of
sit in silence,
and I'm like, "How was it?
You hated it!
I know you hated it!"
And we just have that
kind of struggle.
But it's great.
They're both very good
at kind of being
the supportive parents
and then also giving, like,
professional criticism
and praise and all of that.
-Have you been lucky enough,
or did you feel,
as a young person,
was it lucky to go to sets
that they were working on?
Did you like those visits?
-You know, I have to say they
were boring when I was younger.
It's a lot of waiting.
-Yeah.
They're boring when
you get older, too, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But I was like, "You guys
just don't do any work."
Just a lot of waiting.
But it was, you know,
the difference in sets with both
my parents is extreme
'cause, you know, with my dad,
I'm going onto
the "Mamma Mia!" set, and I'm
like, "Hey, Cher, hey Meryl."
Just like, you know,
with all the A-listers.
And then, with my mom,
it was the "Westworld" set,
and you are just surrounded
by all these corpses.
-Yeah.
-Me and my sister --
They're all prosthetic,
obviously.
And we -- my dad,
we were just bored and like,
"We want to go home."
My dad's like,
"Go play over there
with that dead body."
[ Laughter ]
So we see this kind of
corpse on a stretcher
with a sheet over it.
Me and my sister go over,
and we peel back.
And it's my mom, a prosthetic
version of my mother
looking incredibly --
-There's the lovely Thandiwe.
I mean, this is really
a good example
of how little she's working.
I mean...
[ Laughter ]
That is not a fun thing to see.
Hey, congratulations so much
on the show.
-Thank you very much.
-And thank you so much
for being here.
It's been lovely talking to you.
-Thank you for having me.
-Nico Parker, everybody.
"The Last of Us" premieres
January 15th on HBO.
We'll be right back with music
from Inhaler.